the fine folks over at kink University
my alma mater have sent out a survey to
find out the kinkiest cities in America
they looked at things like you know
where people are doing BDSM fetishes and
polyamorous communities things of that
nature and we've got the cities right
here all right so the top kinkiest
cities Portland San Francisco New York
Chicago Washington DC Los Angeles
Seattle Boston Philly and Vegas I mean
it's basically cities with a lot of
people I support --lens particularly
interesting and Philly so we'll get to
that in a sec and let's just look at how
they actually went about doing this they
looked at the total size of the kink
identified population the size of the
population relative to the cities size
the number of resources available for
kink identified people and the adult
entertainment purchases in each city so
I don't know if you guys watch
Portlandia I love Portland yeah I've
actually never been to Portland I need
to go to Portland I grew up I was a
Portland Trail Blazer fan I always
wanted to go to Portland but there's
something going on in Portland right
like I wanted they let their freak flag
fly
Portland why Portland why is that the
number one kinkiest city do you have any
eye what's going on in the water in the
Pacific Northwest put a bird on it like
sketches all the characters are just so
out there I guess that you would expect
them to be doing this of them look like
they would actually get laid but I think
we know from like you know businessmen
in Japan there's this big thing where
they like to be a lot of them like tied
up and beaten and abused so it's not
just what people look like on the
outside that indicates what they like
I've read that that Portland is the only
city in the u.s. that has a dormant
volcano within its city life so maybe
there's like some yeah it's true maybe
or mid volcano important that's what I
read yeah and so maybe there's some kind
of weird existential thing going on with
all the there
like we could die and yes fly the freak
flag lab from yeah we just throw the
city's up one more time real quick
because what I thought was interesting
that these are all basically big cities
I mean San Francisco New York Chicago
well they're also LA coastal cities
except for Vegas right no stole enough
so but all of these seem like kind of
cool cities to me the only one doesn't
strike me as a cool city is Philly
Philly when I lived in New York I was I
started my PhD in New York and I hated
it I get a lot of hate from very angry
and yeah and I was miserable and it's
cold and I lived in Queens and it was a
beautiful neighborhood in Forest Hills
but I didn't know anybody whatever and
one of my best friends was a medical
school in Philly and I would take the
Chinatown bus to Philly risk my life on
the Chinatown bus literally every
weekend to spend time in Center City in
Philly because I was so obsessed with
Philly yeah it's a great it's got
Reading Terminal it's got there's so
much cool stuff it they got that Bell
like that broken yeah all right let's
not focus on feeling too much either of
you dated anyone of that was
particularly interested in any sort of
kink max go have I you are on the spot
let's go I don't think so I think
they've all been somewhat vanilla that's
my most politically correct Wow
that was boring Cara give me something
here I know you've definitely been
you've got a lip ring in for God's sake
maybe I don't know how do you find kink
well like no I've never really tried I
mean I've dated non-monogamous Lee
before but I've never been in the poly
community I have a lot of friends
actually weirdly in the poly community
but I don't think that would be for me
I'd get too jealous yeah I dated a guy
once who was like a peer cyst and he was
really into like pain so hear it so what
did he want he always wanted to like no
I he didn't want me to do anything but
he always wanted to like Pierce himself
like during and I never was okay wait he
wanted to pierce during sex
he was a peer system he liked so you're
having sex hygienic ly like weirded out
by it so I didn't do it wait so you'd
literally be having sex and he'd want to
he'd want to Pierce himself yeah like
his arm while you were having said yeah
because it like it felt good to him so
he used to he and another piercer friend
or another he worked at
a tattoo shop they used to pierce you
know they would do surface piercings in
their backs or do other things and just
take them out that night they only did
it to like play with designs and because
it felt good yeah a little weird wow
these hurt like hell to me and I don't
get any sort of like sexual excitement
out of it but I I don't think it's the
weirdest kink thing out there I could
see why some people might get sexually
excited I've dated a girl that would
growl yeah where she part wolf yeah I
think she might have been did you like
it I think not really growl like wow I
mean a camera it was a weird primordial
it was more of a growl freaked me out so
I know these stories are all kind of
saying what's your story day yeah not
you know I've been tied up do you think
the kink is more it had nothing to do
with sex I've just been do you think
it's more intense in the LGBT community
on Santa Monica Boulevard there are
definitely like leather shops and you
see a lot of change and people identify
that like [ __ ] masks and things often
right with gay sex not as much with I
don't know that's actually you know I
live in West Hollywood which is like the
the hub of the gay community at least in
Los Angeles and there's this like very
intense leather store just a couple
blocks away from where I live and I
always think it's so interesting because
it's not it makes no difference to me I
walk by it it means nothing to me I
don't think anything weird like that I
know there's some weird they got some
weird stuff like it doesn't strike me
any which way but I know if that was in
a more in a straight community it would
be thought of differently than it does
like in the window and yet it's fully in
the window there so I yeah I mean gay
the gay community in general does view
sex differently or a little freer I
think they're less uptight you know it's
the outsider thing anyway what weird
[ __ ] are you and let us know in the
comments right down below